- Mon doux, combien d'heures
ça fait.mon cinquième 16 heures.
Faites le calcul, je suis trop
fatigué pour calculer. Je suis
désolé.
- Cet émondeur travaille
sans relâche depuis bientôt
une semaine et le travail
est loin d'être terminé.
vers le nord, pire que c'est.
- Dans la municipalité
de Piedmont, nombreux sont
les foye'électrici'électrici'éle
une semaine après la tempête.
GAÉTAN FOURNIER
- On joue à toutes sortes
on va chez ma belle-soeur,
on est allés prendre
nos douches.
- Éric Bainville et sa famille
passeront la fin de semaine
en dehors de leur résidence.
- On a réservé deux nuités
à Montréal. On va s'en alle
parce qu'on n'a pas encore
d'électricité.
- Même si, sur la même rue,
le couraétabli chez
certains de ses voisins.
MARIE-FRANCE GOYETTE
- Hier, tais une
des privilégiées qui en avait
raison bizarre,
mes voisins en n'avaient pas.
Ça fait que je me sentais comme
- C'est un peu ironique,
le soir, assis ici,
je vois e allumée, puis
moi, j'ai pas de courant che
nous.
- Beau temps, mauvais temps,
sont toujours à l'oeuvre.
ERIC FILION, vp Hydro-Québec
- La pluie, évidemment,
nos travaux de construction.
- Hydro-Québec espère pouvoir
rétablir le courant d'ici
dimanche dans l'ensemble
du réseau grâce ade 2000 de
ses employés.
JONATHAN JULIEN
- Les deux à trois dernières
journées qui sont devant nous,
le en fin
de compte de plus
en plus en plus en plus en plus.
- On a des arbres de plus
d'un mètre de diamètre qui sont
arrachés des poteaux.
On va devoir évidemment faire
le ménage de la végétation.
On va devoir aussi planter
des poteaux dans le roc. Ça va
prendre au moins d
40 clients.
- Si la patience de milliers
de résidents est mise à rude
épreuve,
- Tu peux pas être impatient
et être en colère contre
une situation comme ça.
Surtout que les gars sont sur
le terrain puis ils font
ce qu'ils ont à f
Surtout que les gars sont sur
le terrain puis ils font
ce qu'ils ont à faire.
les pieds, donc c'est le temps
qui va rétablir les choses.
Ici Hadi Hassin, Radio-Canada,
Piedmont, dans les Laurenti